jameelah is so wonderful to see you
honey you look so great you look at me
well with isolation I'm personally
someone who's very okay with staying in
my house and the little house cat and I
was very socially anxious person so
being in a house with James is fine by
me for any amount of time and thankfully
we don't not to kill each other yet so
that's good you know that that's how I
feel me my husband are doing well my
kids are doing well so like we're okay
right now in dealing with isolation in a
good way but there's so much going on
you're busy working at home and your
part is something that's so special I'm
so glad to be connecting with you about
this Mira the Royal detective Mira royal
detective this is a moment I will never
forget because what you're doing is
helping my girls have something
reflected of who they look like on TV
what does it mean for you to be part of
a project like this I wanted to do
something like this my entire career and
something that I really really needed as
a kid you know I never got to see a I
never got to see the love interest ever
be someone who was who looked like me it
was always very very skinny often white
princesses with long blonde curly hair
and I longed to see someone who looked
like me and mostly I longed to see a
woman as the arrow a woman is the
protagonist to show a little a little
South Asian girl as the one who solving
all the cases I think it's a really
great message for for young girls and I
think it's also really important message
for young boys and for dads to remember
that sometimes the girl can be the same
year and she has her own story in her
own mission and her own life and and so
I think that that's messaging that we
desperately need when I was a kid and I
would have found that really inspiring
so it's amazing to be part of it I'm
such a cool cast and the whole cast is
Asian I've never seen this that I've
never seen oh cool sheet like it ever it
was it was unbelievable it felt like
home it was great talking about that you
know when we were both brought up we we
dealt with their skin tone we we dealt
with racism and I wanted to know was was
there a person that inspired you the
person that you looked up to us growing
up my nose would be over because Whoopi
Goldberg didn't look like
Nelson Hollywood and she was hosting the
Academy Awards she was a hilarious comic
such a great actress and she had the
kind of roles that I thought were
actually interesting you know it was the
90s and and so women weren't often given
roles as anything other than the sort of
like fainting love interest who's
obsessed with a man and Whoopi always
marched to her the beat of her own drum
to her parts for so different to anyone
elses and you know jumping jack flash
and all these the color purple Jesus
Christ
and so Whoopi was my what he was my hero
now you're a hero to a lot of people
with your new podcasts I weigh and when
I read the description this is what you
wrote working through their pass chains
to find where their value truly lies
which I found so interesting what are
people going to get out of this podcast
that is different from others that are
trying to inspire I don't really listen
to podcasts oh I don't know but I can
tell you that conversations between
people so often from people that you
wouldn't expect them from like how
personal Reese Witherspoon was with me
and how much she opened up to me about
her journey with her mental health and
her struggles and she talks to me about
personal depression and anxiety and
medication and therapy and all these
different things
same with Demi Lovato who went into so
much detail with me about her history
with her eating disorders and her body
image and have mental health and
addiction so I think that that's a
really rare thing as I but I'm very
lucky to have access to these people and
for whatever reason they feel safe
telling me these things like we saw it
with Sam Smith ilysm last year and so
that's a huge privilege but also I think
that you're just the hope is that the
reason I made it was so that people
would feel less alone
I made this podcast to demystify and D
stigmatize mental illness for people so
that you know if they know that someone
like me or someone you know on my
podcast are struggling with something
they will feel less alone in there's you
know we want to make people feel less
ashamed and not feel like they have to
keep these things secret because we are
all going through these things and
there's nothing wrong with you and it's
not your fault I
and we want to offer you a little bit of
hope because a lot of the people on the
podcast of people who are on the other
side of that trauma and while they're
working through it successfully and and
so I just want to offer people a kind of
just a bit of a lifeline even if it's
just for an hour and also just a break
from everyone they're living with it's
an hour to hear an often very
inappropriate conversation in private
away from their children away from your
husband away from you know you are a
force you had the ability to use this
platform your voice is to be able to
talk about your truths and I think
that's why they're so comfortable with
you is that they can share that with you
because they can relate to you where do
you get that confidence to be able to
put that out there so freely I think I
just I can't keep it in stop so you know
I feel even when I should but it was a
decision I made consciously about eight
years ago I was I was I was very very
depressed and mentally ill as a response
to as a result of repressing myself all
the time and replacing all of my
feelings and emotions and just taking
nonsense from other people and allowing
myself to be hurt again and again again
and so it was the decision I made of
just like you know what I'm just going
to push back I'm gonna fight back I'm
going to speak back I'm gonna speak up
and speak out and I'm no longer going to
bottle anything up until I get rid of
this depression this feeling of
repression I'm not going to repress
myself at all until I can gain back my
feeling of autonomy and so that's where
that comes from and also just I grew up
as a victim of bad role models yeah and
it really really impacted the way that I
looked at my body the way that I you
know I measured my values in the world
the way that I thought women were
supposed to behave all of that you know
I thought I was supposed to be the cute
hot little Lolita from the film you know
where I'm supposed to always look young
and always look sexy and always look
like a lost little girl that's what
women are taught to perpetuate whereas
now I don't subscribe to that now I want
to I want to look like I know where I am
on a magazine cover I don't want to
smile just because I'm told to I don't
want to look lost
like I'm waiting for a man to come and
save me I'm perfectly capable and I
think that we need to also show more
like ability and maturity a sexy you
know not just the young lost helpless on
you so it's just been it's just a
process for me and it's an interesting
balance because because you're open and
you're making these conversations happen
who's also a backlash you get people on
social media that are not agreeing with
you and that could also take a mental
toll on you how do you deal with that I
mean there were moments with kim
kardashian there were moments with other
celebrities how do you feel about that
do you suppress that or you just like I
have to have this conversation to make
this movement happen I have to have the
conversation to make movement happen and
you have to you have to be attention
seeking and you have to rile people up
sometimes I'm a provocateur in order to
make the conversation so big that it's
trending and then everyone starts
getting involved and even if it's via me
being called out because I've made a
mistake because of that being so public
now loads of other people who would know
moan otherwise now know what not to do
don't mess up the way that I did I'm
very happy to be used in that position
so I'm fine when the backlash is to do
with something relevant I'm not okay
when the backlash is is a lie like an
egregious slanderous slanderous lied
like the one about me having
Munchausen's in February that's that's
not okay that's that's the new art of
discrediting the women that we cannot
kill discrediting is the new death and
we do it to women who speak out we look
we go we go peeling through all of their
their history to find something to prove
that they are alive because we are
afraid of their beliefs so I'm not okay
with salon de but I'm fine with
criticism and so I expect the backlash
not any am I sometimes wrong and I
sometimes mess up but also I'm a woman I
mean a woman when if we ever allow an
outspoken woman's just exist we
celebrate and we silence women so I knew
I was getting myself into
you know one of the things I love is
just looking at this gorgeous cover of
you courses of changes on the vogue
British Vogue magazine
it's a moment guest edited by Royal
Highness the Duchess of Sussex what did
it mean to
be part of that group of women and to be
celebrated that way that was one of the
highlights of my career and it was
incredible that someone I look up to so
much like Megan it's like Megan Marco
who was the person who had put me on
that cover but also the fact that I was
there I was Attenberg and Lauren Laverne
Cox and and Jane Fonda all these people
you know like all the people that I look
up to so much on that cover with me and
also know that it was a non it wasn't at
all airbrushed and we've all wore no
makeup and we were all in pajamas or I
was in pajamas anyway
pajamas I shot it at 7 a.m. but it just
it was an incredibly liberating moment
where the people on the front cover
weren't there for being beautiful or
thin we were there because of something
that we've done it was because of our
action rather than our aesthetic and
whether or not it marked it sort of you
know it matched that patriarchal ideal
we were there for our minds rather than
thank you for what you're doing it's
incredible what you're doing for my
girls and I think they're gonna
appreciate in the next few years that
you're using your voice the way you are
and I hope I can join you and make that
difference as well